and we'll help you out Erica is with us
in New Orleans hi Erica how are you I'm
doing well Dave how are you better than
I deserve what's up all right well my
problem is I was behind on my student
loans so I set up an auto pay with
navient and what happened was I set up
the auto payment and they're still
calling my aunt they sent her a letter
to garnish start garnishing her wages
because she was my cosigner and I don't
know like was that legal of them even
though I kind of the cosigner that she's
a cosigner they can call her all the
time yeah I tried to tell her that but
you know she's really stressed out about
it and I'm like I stressed me out
because I'm making payments so I don't
really understand why they would have to
garnish her wages if I'm already making
payments I don't have to wear their Dom
you're dealing with now have you noticed
how stupid the people are you're talking
to yes yeah I mean that they're the
parents are cousins I mean seriously
they're dumber than dirt so that's the
problem you've got is you're trying to
negotiate a deal with stupid people and
how much do you owe on the student loan
it's 20 over 26,000 right and one of the
payments you've arranged to pay I've
arranged to pay two hundred and eighty
seven dollars which is the minimum for
both loans it's two loans
she's only co-signed one there's two
loans with navient so I've arranged to
pay two hundred eighty seven dollars
which is a minimum payment for both of
them on the fourth of every month so
what happened was when I set up the
first auto pay they kicked back my
dollar saying that they entered the
routing number and the account number
wrong so then I wasn't on auto pace and
they were forcing me to pay to
sixty-seven which I told them I did not
have at the time sorry if they did not
take the money out of your account why
did you not have it I didn't have the
dot I didn't have the 267 so much
because they were only supposed to take
$1.00 to set up the auto pay
so that's that's the the problem is I
didn't I don't really have a really good
paint job so I have to pick up a
part-time job to save up to pay for them
in April on April 4th which was supposed
to be the first day
what do you manage the money out right
now I'm at five like a little over a
thousand every two weeks okay you're
saying that I am married
what does he make he makes about I want
to say twelve hundred for the month are
the two of you doing a budget together
yes we are we actually are in a
Financial Peace University class at the
time at the moment and we have I mean
we're we're really into it and you know
we've got our budget we do our budget
meetings we do our cash envelopes
they're looking for that extra job good
so we're doing all that and and so this
is and I set up a different account for
Sallie Mae so that they don't take the
money out of my bank is really but I set
money aside for them to take out from
their good they're not gonna garnish
your wages there that you're not behind
enough for them to do that right now
they're just trying to harass you and
it's working so I would just call them
back and go okay let's start again since
you people aren't competent we talked
about you taking a dollar out to get
this thing set you didn't try to take a
dollar out you try to take more out and
it messed up you had the routing number
wrong so let's reset again let's see if
you can get the routing number right and
the money will be there when you guys go
to get it next month okay and then you
keep putting the money in there and not
let this thing bump again but if you can
get it on autopilot like you're trying
to do it with that separate account
that's gonna work for you but you're
gonna have to hold their little hands
and make sure that they've got it right
right and reset but they're not gonna go
after her yes they can call her because
she's a cosigner but they're you know
right now they're sitting there on the
verge of getting money from you and they
screwed the routing number up they can
garnish your wages but they're not going
to okay they're just jacking people
around to see what they can get because
that's what stupid people do
okay aggravating is crap but the only
way the answer to it is the bigger
picture of what you all are doing you
and your husband are putting your heads
and your incomes together you rolling up
your sleeves and the biggest thing is
get this crap out of your life so you
never have people like this again that
you have to deal with right that's the
overall thing and that's the working
extra and selling stuff and being on a
tight budget and those things that
you're already doing that are very very
wise so yeah I think you just got a beat
you know go back in there and start
punching again get the things set back
up and you're gonna be fine you're gonna
be fine hey you guys Rachael Cruz here
hope you are enjoying the Dave Ramsey
show and did you know that I have my
very own YouTube channel yes that's
right it's kind of better than the same
room the channel don't tell them I said
that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you